since we're in the old apartment this
feels good doesn't it yeah it doesn't it
isn't it weird it is weird what did you
get how to get some great white you know
oh no way really no no really I had to
pick up from somewhere else but
it is a breakfast burrito just like how
we used to yeah this is how we're gonna
celebrate five years oh yeah is by
eating on the mic dude mad casual this
is great this is this is really great I
missed you I miss you too bro being
right here damn with the with the
pineapple let me get the little shelf
thing here I believe she stayed there
the whole time I know well I've just
I've just continued
renting this apartment yeah just in case
we've ever wanted to do this Bring It
Back to Basics I've just continued this
has been you know five years now people
don't realize that's why you've been
doing all these brand deals yeah it's
just going to preserve expensive yeah
yeah rent's gone up on this [ __ ]
yeah it turns out it's not economical to
rent an apartment that you're not using
or subleasing or anything it's been
empty